[Music] what up citizens of the reject Nation
it is time for Scott Pilgrim we are going to
watch episode five and six today John you
good I'm so good G how are you dude leave
a like on this video guys that would be very
much appreciated also be sure to subscribe
and click that notification notifi when our
reaction with the last two episodes are up
here on the Chanel big thank you to prepper
for helping us edit down these highlights
and lastly massive thank to all of you who
have become super sex Ser X by joining our
patreon page that's where you can catch the
full length rtion watch along where you sync
up with your own copy of Scott Pilgrim takes
off we also cover several things over there
exclusively with highlights and watch alongs
included let's see what this next to are all
about the following documentary began
as a behind the-scenes it's Weird Al
the release of the major Canadian Motion
Picture Scott Pilgrim's precious little
life you caught that voice fast during the
process the movie fall apart this footage
now stands as a firsthand account of how
the movie making dream can become become
what a nightmare okay death and death inside
the Dream Factory is it true neither of you
have acted before yes but we're very very
famous and that's basically the same thing
truth I knew you
will have a Punisher shirt on though world looks
like it and now instead of Brie Larson singing
it it's the crowd singing it we're rock stars we
do what we want and what we want right now is to
be movie [Laughter] stars lights camera Sparks
uhoh Sparks Nicholas Sparks people keep asking
me if the movie lives up to my vision I guess
cronenburg for president that Canadian Cinema
love my mom says I should get m check we're just
trying to honor Mr Neil's tremendous script which
I think is truly a tribute to this great City say
Tonto is a character in the movie sounds so much
like Kevin McDonald aren't we supposed to be
interviewing Envy Adam stunt double now does
she oh I'm Ramona Flowers they said I should
come talk to you her hair is blending in with
the green screen uhoh you're the stunt double
for Ramona Flowers and your name is also Ramona
Flowers mhm meta oh she's full of [__] Ramona
huh when you're done up there I've got another
stunt for you was this just to get close to
Envy I need you to run over to my hotel room
and give my dog some medication it'll be in
a blue bag on the counter like all good stunt
doubles she's also your assistant I only took
this job because security realized I wasn't
working on the movie and I needed an excuse to
be on set so I could get close enough to Todd
to find out if he used a vegan portal the Todd no
stunts today I just wanted to ask Todd you're not
wanted here Ramona we're acting okay so skate
on wow what a symbolic shot that documentary
you gotten your classes huh yeah I finally got
a prescription there sunglasses H oh wow I was
wondering from heckling on the sidelines
to lead in a major Canadian Blockbuster
I decided the only thing better
than being me was getting paid to
be me true that influencer why don't we
try having Scott gently put his hand on
Ramona's back oh sheeps all right Todd
just a gentle little touch do it again
wowe action oh my God this is an
adult film Scott Pilgrim takes it off3
43 put Wallace in between
them oh I go wrong together
since we were 11 years old
every day more magical than the last
how was she when she did Scott maybe
we just need to rethink the scene
this is the dumb version but what
if SC and Wallace let's look at
each other deep into each other's
eyes You' never seen eyes like these
in your life oh what's what's about
to happen yes no kiss kiss I yes yes oh
my God no damn get them tongues going
what am I
oh a bisexual vegan would you do us a
huge favor and give us to Envy Adams
we wrote a song for her to sing at
the movie She embarrassing between
the last number and all that jazz and the
first number in gree 2 yes Greece 2 love
what just happened Sparks not sure want
to run lines in your trailer do I love
making animation of the movement great about
script run lines in your
trailer nice lines in your
trailer lines trailer I started using that as
short hand we experimented with other people he
dated Ramona I dated Scott Pilgrim that's
why there we go he went to my high school
junior year he told me the love of his life
was waiting for him back in Canada he also
told me that he liked to live in the moment
that generally meant sloppy makeouts behind
the school yum yum is it true he punched a hole
in the moon for you teleported to the moon and
absolutely the most romantic thing
I've ever seen the most horrifying
thing I've ever seen oh he did it
all for you we need to talk about
Scott Pilgrim I'm Scott Pilgrim all
idiots L's hold that they're on method
co-worker no super saiyan vegan at the end of day
two the production was already $7 million over
budget what's it like working with Wallace Wells
she's taught me so much about acting no about
living what can you even say about a man like that
no B hold it eny I can't be with you anymore I'm
in love with Wallace wow wowe I'm a new person a
new boy my skin is clear it's love things change
when you become Scott any rumors about me having
a very hot onset Affair or just rumors I'm here
tell him what you just told me oh boy oh no oh
no he's in love with me isn't he well Wallace is
used to this oh buddy this was just an onset fling
what when the movie ends so does the relationship
a what about the Sparks oh what sparks no
sweetheart oh no I like the camera movement a
lot Wallace weld oh you broke my boyfriend
prepare to die Ramona like that they acknowledge
the camera oh that bum stop stop it stop it
if you want to fight with me fight with them
whoa the stunt doubles why does Wallace
have stunt doubles I don't know time for
stunts wait what I'm doing an interview do
you want to keep your job Ramona versus The
Wallace stunt doubles I like that nvy Adams
is like slightly taller than Ramona [Music]
desp I like how this hops in and out of the
documentary Wells versus Adams Wallace Wells
who said that uh nobody who's the narrator he's
great yeah straight Wallace you're a stunt double
now why are you acting like that's weird you made
the exact same career chain yes I did it for very
specific reason you got demoted straight Wallace
oh here we go go Marshall Club on it Ramona that's
the sloppiest headbutt I've ever seen thought this
supposed to look like a handheld one TI yeah come
on cool choreography damn yeah whoa she's like
a compa fighter what last time you hit the gym
too many french fries we can handle physical abuse
but we draw the line and verbal abuse yeah they're
fighting for your honor man that's not how you
motivate they need positive reinforcement why
does your character want to fight Wallace in the
first place I broke her boyfriend you and Todd
should have put that together Ramona no more
stunts where is he yeah the handheld motion's
great like it's it feels very authentic oh Todd
fat Thor breaking vegan Edge CH cheese fries
this the first place I made out with Wallace
this is the second place yep yep yep blumkin
what we had was fun but I've discovered our new
kind of fun would you care about another person
no no now i''d be chasing that high for the
rest of my life You Can't Fight The Moonlight
babe no a constellation it's a vegan portal all
right but it's better than anything Todd's ever
made I mean look at the thought that went
into it the craftsmanship Todd didn't do
this it's like a prime vegan you have no other
leads tragic looks like you're never going to
find him what do you know did Envy do it
she could have done it I think she might
have done it is she a vegan or a twins I
guess I mean env's the only other vegan
we know of right she is vegan I just assumed
yeah and she's dating Todd might she might
be Matthew Patel oh with the G belt damn
everyone here works for me right yes sir
good you're all fired why aren't you the director
yes you're fired Oh no I got wrong you shooting a
documentary or something uh uhhuh well not anymore
hey bab get off me bab stop no no it was all F I
was enjoying the mockumentary Stu I punched Scott
Pilgrim to death you didn't actually punch him to
death someone kidnapped him and made it look like
you won I didn't win he's not dead no no Patel's
going to have to go find him is he mad at me is
is he mad at me the Empire's mind I won't make
the same mistakes he made I won't end up where he
is now which is where exactly here Toronto he's
shacking up with some girl named Julie something
oh did you know Gideon isn't even his real name
it's Gordon Gordon Goose I guess Gan of the one
who did it Julie it wouldn't be Julie Powers or
did Julie do it Julie didn't like Scott I want
everybody's food purchases on my desk maybe it
was what they eat where they big plan to get
Gideon back maybe Julie pow and I need to talk
what do you know Robo she got the shiny glasses
it's not good hypnotized by the TV no evil anime
glasses okay it is Kevin McDonald as uh Edgar
wrong next episode starting three two 1 go oh
yes that's what I'm talking
about what it's a real anime
now who's this I don't
[Music] know oh
[Music] ouch taka just watch one of
the animes that inspired this or or
like the Studio's traditional style
maybe Goose I'm looking for Graves
Gideon who the hell is goose you've
reached the adult formally known as
gide Graves it's the goose now Gordon
Goose my name isn't Lucas actually it's
Luke well here's how I see you Goose I've
lost everything you've lost everything I
thought maybe you'd have some words of
advice a I know I left you in the Lurch
after Matthew but if you could find it
in your heart to forgive me forgiveness
is what you want oh he wants revenge I
have something entirely different in mind
uhoh looks so much like Billy
Butcher and The [Music] [Applause]
Punisher hey hey hey hey
a whoa hey don't get it
twisted it's almost as if letting go of Ramona
Flowers has worked wonders for everyone but I
do keep questioning if I hadn't seen the
movie would I care to find Scott I mean
that's another good question if this was your
first introduction to all of them you wouldn't
really be any of the wiser would I be yeah yeah
would I care about the motivation you [Music]
know indoor house half pipe let's
go oh yeah I was going to
say that's not how you drop
in is that an anime we don't
actually know about it could
be my I was gone for 90
minutes and what's with the
robot what robot hey hey
that ain't no
Roomba
oh o got the die the last one didn't have the die
it's because it was a documentary
episode they weren't there for
this is this just to distinguish the
episodes you know it's her her changing moods
and and her growth through color who did it
who did it Ryan Johnson episode Julie I'll make
this brief is that the sound of skates eye here
tell to come in here and kick it so it's you
and Gideon now no that's Gordon Gordon Goose
be back in a bit baby okay bye I'll miss you I'll
miss you more I think the the big end game was to
get him back AUB Plaza diabolical bre makes
you too obvious bread Makes You full and how
did you get the CEO of Gman media to bankroll
your project Mr Patel had the capital but he
was also an aspiring Broadway Theater obsessive I
read an interview with him in Forbes yes sniv an
Off Broadway musical and who better to play the
lead than you not a lot of people know this but
I made majored in theater in college it shows
briefly start in my own onean show let's see
it
yes Agony misery wo though it's different for
each wow whoever got this on video got some
really great angles wow impressive you uh think
he's got the chop Stephen say yes I've made my
decision Scott Pilgrim's precious little musical
near the go project I got a go picture hope you
know how much we value your opinion pal we're
adapting your work after all oh I don't I don't
care about the movie shutting down it didn't mean
anything to me I'm just having my own golf cart
Young Neil I don't even remember writing it uh
I dreamed I saw my sleep paralysis demon at my
computer and I woke up the next day and there it
was who is the demon we have to tell Ramona about
this she's the one who's been searching for Scott
this whole time really you two moved on with your
lives when we saw Ramona on the movie Set you
were as cool as a cucumber that was business oh
emotional business oh no emotional business can
I get a witness stop when I was in high school in
Northway Ontario Gordon Goose was the weirdest kid
in my year his glass glasses were too big for his
face his clothes fit funny even his hair looked
wrong still got the same shirt yep he wore those
no fear t-shirts every day one day out of nowhere
he presents the most popular girl in school with
a 12-point business plan as to why she should date
him yeah I have no fear of the sting of rejection
therefore there's no downside to me attempting
this damn this some pretty moving facts and
figures oh no no I had no idea Gideon Graves was
the dorky kid from my past until he turned up on
my doorstep made made him into a cool guy that
day Gordon was a Twitchy rage-filled impulsive
emotionally abusive controlling manipulative
egomaniac hey man he was rich when Gordon
showed up he was power hungry he wanted Revenge
he would have done anything to get his Empire back
but after a few days it's like the evil drained
out now he just sits on the couch watching anime
all day maybe none of the other exes were in
on it maybe it was all Gman or maybe the two
of you were in on it together n he's just a loser
trust me you can take him or us off your list the
twins hey so his real name is Gordon Goose oh
no God damn it Stacy were you e dropping you
shouldn't be here on your day day off oh scoot
scoot on out of here I was gone for 90 minutes
oh nice little time Loop yeah I said earlier that
morning yeah I just got so caught up in I forgot
where have I seen that robot she seems pissed
does this mean I can't live here live here oh
no I don't care which one of you did it you're
both going to pay Julie Bowers versus and Gordon
o stop stop this is stupid what find your
own place I'm flat broke I can't even afford
a first class flight back to LA and the only
work I can get is voicing an animated series
Lucas Le live action or nothing how do he lose
everything I don't know that robot where have
I seen it before you know who made him right
that's their special little guy right there
the twins there you go oh Metal Gear
oh good catch it did say he was like
cancelled after that so maybe they they
really meant it lost everything yeah my
man oh you son of a [__] show really captures
the sadness to the League what if I said that
while it seemed like I wasn't doing anything
and was throwing a pity party I was actually
planning an elaborate plan a plan that would
turn Matthew Patel into dust I'd say hot that's
hot yeah yeah oh boy oh boy what are you
all doing here we have information about
your case your Scott case what if I told you
I cracked the case wide open would any of you
want to hear what I figured out let's compare
info now she's buddies with it everybody wants
they Scot back I've been trying to figure out
who did it why they did it and how they did
it and now I know all three let's start with
the who yes by now most of you know about my
past I've dated a lot of people who were
suspect that's a similar word to suspects
wow the twins Ken and Kyle katayanagi they were
my Tas in robotics 101 excellent and that leads
to the why oh they have the motivation okay it
was was my second semester of college I didn't
know what I was doing I was a kid but to the
twins I was fresh meat they were a couple of
players and they wouldn't leave me alone it's Al
just how creepy dudes can be baked into the show
so maybe I got a little bit of satisfaction when
they figured out I was playing them right back I
was dating both of them at the same time tabik
the how is a vegan portal but this portal far
exceeded the power level of my only vegan X what's
more powerful than a human vegan two human vegans
a robot vegan yes of course a robot that's never
eaten meat a vegan without the inherent flaws of
humanity created by the twins dang
so every robot can create a vegan
portal it was at the rocket before sex
went on stage oh it was on the vide
tape I like how the flashbacks on the
videotape or how they were on the show
that even like from the perspective of the
security camera yeah where where is he we'll
know soon enough when I find the twins I find
Scott boom Young Neil didn't write that script
he didn't write Scott F precious little
life oh no we didn't figure out the who
the why or the how but we did figure out the
when according to the file data that script
was written 14 years from now whoa I just got
write the script in the future on a different
timeline you might be right yeah Scott
hey Scott Where Have You you been was
it the twins are you okay I'm okay and
yes it was the twins okay someone else
was behind the whole thing who me it
was me what I did it Scott how could
you sho dang Scott's a horrible
person yeah [__] Scott
Pilgrim all right all right dang you know the
clothes these guys wear in the show are so so
fly yeah you think so John they are some of the
flyest but I think I might have seen flyer clothes
maybe once or twice in my life I would like to
buy their clothes sometimes I like to buy other
YouTubers clothes like Double Toasted you know I
think it's important to support YouTube channels
that you watch by buying their merch I think it's
important as well just like how John's wearing the
real reject merch right here who influences the
influencers I like this channel called the real
reject and I wanted to support so I got that's
a real sweet gesture of you to do yeah any the
whole time man real rejects has shirts that
hey could be good Christmas presents as well
the best Christmas presents like they got this CH
Protection Services one look at that Pedro and uh
baby yod and then you also got space babies of
the Galaxy right here love those babies we also
have the aoda shirts the aoda and the snip Snips
and and then we got a there's a whole bunch of
that's a bunch of shirts here dude there's so many
and I hear a new one a Christmas one that's being
worked on it's a kind of a weird one but it's a
Christmas one wow dang you got the inside track
on this stuff I do it's crazy it's important for
me to have leaking the designs get a hype going
out there early so guys yeah I mean if you want
to just go to like www.en.com and then um either
gift yourself or gift someone this holiday season
while also showing your support for real rejects
it's a great way to go about it John what you
think of these episodes oh goodness I mean I
wish we could keep talking about shop reject
nation.com but I guess we'll talk about the
show re.com reject Nation shop.com that shop
boy can melts brains seen some of these other
intros people be like what is the shop name and
usually I'm like it's not that hard but here we
are so anyhow reject Nation shop.com I like these
episodes quite a bit it's you you mentioned at
one point that they're really good at zeroing
in on The Melancholy with the X's but I think
overall they're kind of good at at zeroing in on
this sort of peripheral Melancholy that everyone
is experiencing to some degree and so yeah I just
continue to be sort of drawn in and and fascinated
by the atmosphere they have here because there
is like I don't know it just everything kind of
matches the setting you know you're in kind of
a colder environment anyway there is a sort of
cold that all the characters are working through
um but but yeah I don't know there's also like
kind of a nice warmth of camaraderie in here and
uh this was quite tumultuous and it makes sense
I guess that at episode 6 we would at least have
like the main mystery wrapped um but yeah I mean
I've loved you know the the the first episode we
watched with Todd Ingram was just so so kind of
wild um and then the who did it episode was was
more kind of like focusing in and really getting
to the the meat of things so I think I had a bit
more like outright fun with the first episode we
watched today but uh I'm enjoying just the grace
with which all of this is unfolding really yeah
yeah I really like the documentary one a lot um
I thought the way they messed around with their
camera angles on that one just the the energy
the vibe of that one the pacing of it uh was
really to my liking and uh just the amount of meta
commentary that they were doing on top of all that
as well then anything playing on like filmmaker
mockumentary sensibilities and something that's
just going to tickle my fancy but even messing
with the relationship with Todd and envy Adams
was a really fun thing to to dish out you know
like one of the jokes in the movie of the Scott
Pilgrim movie uh with Wallace was like the amount
of action this guy can get and so to see him like
manipulate uh oh God Tod fall in love with him and
how it's like becoming this destructive part on
set and their relationship uh was a really joyous
experience and then it even led to a really cool
fight scene with uh Ramona Flowers I thought you
know I I feel like they're not really going to be
doing much with MV uh it seems like she's the one
who's not really I mean she's not one of Ramona's
xes and this is way more Ramona show right now
than is Scott show Scott will punch her by the
end of the series we'll do that let's hope so yes
so we have that to deal with and yeah the followup
episode was still very enjoyable it was just such
a high from the mockumentary one yeah because I
even like when you start off with the rock concert
and just like the amount of jokes that they were
made like I thought it was just a really funny
fun expressive episode and then the follow-up
one I don't know the Julie character is like she's
enjoyable to me Gideon is he's enjoyable to me I
don't quite love watching them they're like I said
they're they're enjoyable but they're not they're
they're kind of on the bottom of the list for
me yeah in a way I feel like the impact of Audy
Aubrey Plaza maybe hits a little harder in the
live action because she is able to like really
bring her there's so much in her expressions
and her dead pness yeah and like I like what
she does here I like the work here and I you know
enjoy the animation of the character and all that
stuff but yeah like I feel like she in this medium
isn't transposed in as much of a way to like not
still feel like you're dealing with like a bit
I don't know like in the movie she's a kind of
a bit character but like when you're focused
in on her there's still like a gravity that
that she's the center of the the moments she's in
whereas this feels like she's more of just like a
regular supporting character who swears a lot yeah
and I like Goose's backstory in the high school
that was a really uh telling flashback that I it
made me care more about him and it made me find
his character significantly more interesting
I liked him and Lucas Lee together yeah that
bond is nice most yeah of his storyline uh the the
part the part of the show that's semi missing for
me because we're six episodes in and I and I do
think this this part is kind of missing for me is
that pgri is not even that uh is is that we have
and like I like the ending mystery not there are a
bit of that like Wonder stranger things Vibes to
the mystery unfolding and you know like there's
no rules to this world uh which I enjoy every
Everything nowadays always like what's the rules
what's the rules so it's kind of refreshing to
watch something that just Embraces we don't have
rules here yeah or if we do the logic only makes
sense to like somebody yeah per episode to someone
behind the camera and they're not going to tell
you what those rules are yeah which gives it an an
an anarchic kind of fun spirit that way yeah yeah
so I I enjoy that about this show but we've spent
so much time getting to know other people and and
I kind of just feel like we our main character is
Ramona and if you're going to make that choice I
want to get to know Ramona better like we kind of
get to know the characters that she's talking
to like the exes we get to know each one of
the exes we get to know better and then even like
hearing about the flashbacks yeah and maybe we'll
get that in the last couple of episodes or maybe
the last episode I don't I don't know um so that
is one part of it that I'm like I do wish that a
little bit per episode we did get to know a little
bit better like sure we've seen her in the high
school and her story of their stories of falling
in love with people and okay she's got a fighting
background I guess and then she was a little bit
conniving as as a sophomore in in college sure
but you know like it works the structure of
keeping Ramona a mystery makes so much more sense
when the whole point is you're watching it from
Scott's perspective Ive and he's uncovering the
x's and then it makes the X's more mysterious and
it makes the game of foot a lot more fun but
if you're making remota the main character uh
you got to do something to make her a little more
interesting yeah we got to get a bit more personal
with her because it's like all these she's such
a dry personality too yeah and she's such a
motivating factor for so many characters and like
I like her presence in the moment certainly like
her in the- moment presence but yeah I would agree
like like getting feeling like these episodes of
each brought us a bit more of an emotional context
for Ramona or brought us closer to her in some way
I still feel about as close or distant as you
know we were kind of from the beginning from
the first episode yeah yeah and and yeah and that
first episode when they're you know when she and
Scott are you know having those intimate moments
together those are some of the most tender you get
with her and I like that each episode they take
the time to repeat that ritual of her dying her
hair to suit her you know new moods and Pursuits
and whatever you know it's not the same as uh
spending some additional emotional time with the
character beyond the physical Motif and I know
part of the humor of and the sensibility of the
Scott Pilgrim world show and movie is there's no
real in between from apathy to extremity you
know and and so she falls on like everyone of
Scott's friends other than knives Chow you know
every SC like okay you got like young Neil like
super apathetic and then you have nice CH was
like very extreme yeah and then the drummer very
apathetic totally totally so every character Ste
Stills is very emotional yeah every character is
either apathetic or extreme right yeah and Ramona
would fall under the apathetic category sure so
when this is like a motivating driving force for
her for some unpronounced reason even to herself
that she doesn't quite understand you know uh
it it loses some of that drive so when you get
a slower episode like episode six yeah it does
show that it's a slower episode in a way that I
don't entirely find complimentary sure it makes me
wonder if because I for the most yeah five I would
I would sing its Praises like all day you know
I thought everyone was great ramono included you
know everyone's great but that's a real Ensemble
thing whereas the six slows down a lot to focus on
two very apathetic characters yeah yeah 100% yeah
and and then the Gideon back story was the most
interesting part of it yeah it it makes me wonder
if if that will be an earmark of the binge because
thus far I have felt like most of these stand
pretty I mean you know they're compact so you want
to watch a bunch of them but they stand pretty
solidly on their own I wonder if that thread may
be one that stands more in totality like certainly
hope and would expect that the next two episodes
hold some physical and emotional cathares and and
you know developments for Ramona and so maybe in
hindsight those wall register but I you know in
the here and now I can't deny that you know aspect
of it yeah and then that rests more on the actual
who done it which you know isn't like which is the
mystery but it's not like an impossible mystery at
least right now because you know especially when
we get to the end of the episode and it's like
well you kind of narrowed it all down and those
are logical kind of conclusions now the question
is why Scott did all this yeah yeah yeah so you
know I think this episode certainly kind of leaves
you especially if you're going to take a minute's
break with a couple things that are maybe a little
more questionable than just you know appreciation
as a lot of a lot of the episodes leave me just
like appreciating various things and then this one
yeah leaves me more contemplating and curious
about again what's going to be ahead rather
than just what I what's here right now you know
yeah yeah cuz I think the first one of the most
appealing Parts about the first episode to me was
how it's heart and soul and its Melancholy really
saying hi and I think whenever that's sprinkled
in with the comedy that's when it's working at its
strongest the show yeah is when there is a genuine
sense of emotionality and um yeah it's not like I
didn't like the the sixth episode I just thought
it was on the weaker side of a very strong show
yeah still strengths in the episode which is not
not the one I would identify as the strongest yeah
when but when you're like getting close to the end
and it is your who done itep it is your big like
who did it episode I felt like it should have had
a bit more of an impact I'm curious because again
I again as we've often touched on like I I out of
Eight Episodes I'm curious about the placement of
it as number six for certain of the functions of
this because we do have two more and often times
I associate like a second to last episode with
like okay here's some emotional and you know any
kind of big physical resolutions and then next
episode we're going to kind of pay off all of
the themes and then set up for the future so this
is uh I wonder you know if there's not another big
subversion or some other kind of shoe to drop or
surprise to come and maybe they're luring us into
like a false sense of like okay well we know
most of what happened and now we just got to
wrap it all up you know maybe there's something
else here we'll see guys what did you think the
episode leave your thoughts down below uh be
sure to subscribe leave a like and hey let's
send us with a patron the day shout out Gabriel
we're thankful for you today you're getting a
solo shout out one of the rare ones this month
as there's time you better be thankful Gabriel
for this I assume you're in these United States
even though you're no angel you are a benevolent
kind person who has been here supporting us for
far too long for far too long especially when we
you know made all those tacky Angel Gabriel jokes
that I now regret and we'll never ever reference
we were hoping we could pressure you we were
hoping we could but you know you didn't need
pressured you stuck around you know we don't
follow religion but we thought it' be funny
if we can convert you yeah exactly we we care
about your soul here at the patreon we want you
to be with us during the Rapture as we Ascend in
God's CED hands you know to Valhalla and we don't
want you to slip through like you know the waters
tyranny and idle uh handedness uh Gabriel we want
you to be exalted at our side blessed uh by the
host of of the Heavenly uh you know promise that
Jesus has left for us this is our way of saying
thank you thank you Gabriel on this Thanksgiving
month yes if you open your Bible to any any of
the gospels Jesus had a dinner with his friends
you could pretend like you're having worst thing
you could have done Gabriel is is after us making
a bunch of jokes about angel [__] is then come
back and tell us you're an atheist cuz then we're
just going to double down yep yep yep these are
going to be the most Pious by now you you should
have known that this probably the directory
would have gone next month's shout out we're
just going to say the rosary for like 40s through
the whole thing you know how many get we're going
live stream of mass yes we're going to rent the
local church out we're going to invite people and
it's all going to be in your honor you know so I
hope you appreciate I hope you too if you don't
tune in live it's going to be really embarrassing
man but uh in all seriousness thank you for being
here for so long it's been a very long time you've
been here man and uh thank you for not wavering
yeah we love you and I hope to keep you around
uh definitely for sure definitely if you uh go
to heaven with us so uh thank you for being you
and looking forward to coming up with something
non-religious next month for you lift up your
hearts we'll deliver you from evil Gabriel